what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with kingdom come part three
yes enter shazam so i know this is
probably the one that a lot of you guys
have been waiting for um who were aware
of what we did you know in the last
video where we talked about how shazam
was a part of it it was pretty obvious
it's it's really really awesome right
check this out what we end up getting
here and one of the things to keep in
mind is that it's not necessarily the
specter and this is something that i
that i saw in the comments it's not
necessarily the specter that's taking
norman mckay on all these journeys if
anything it's the visions of norman
mckay that's leading the spectre on all
of this because remember the spectre is
there to judge some future evil and he's
very cloak and dagger whenever he talks
to uh norman mckay about exactly what
he's there for or what his purpose is we
as the audience are well aware of the
spectre we're well aware of how dark and
twisted he can be but also how good he
can be just depending on who he's bonded
to at that particular point in time or
whether his spirit's gone insane but
that's something that we'll actually
talk about here in a little while but at
the moment switching back to earth what
you get is the completion of this prison
that has basically been built by
superman oddly enough it looks like that
old legion of doom headquarters from the
uh what is it the super friends where
aquaman rode around on a seahorse
and talked to fish that show did more
damage to aquaman as a character than
any meme that's ever been created by
humanity
because of that show everybody's like
aquaman rides seahorses and talks to
fish and no one could take him seriously
anymore but the thing about this is that
this prison that's being built here is a
really cool discussion because what the
specter says is that once the kansas
wastelands were stripped of radiation
superman's penitentiary was fast
completed the gulag was built to
imprison the deadliest and most
uncontrollable of the superhumans thanks
to its vast size it was intended to
house prisoners for months to come
within two weeks of its construction it
was filled beyond capacity and what this
illustrates here and is one of the most
important things what this illustrates
here is to a degree how quickly superman
is falling now a lot of this is coming
off the heels of wonder woman that's one
of the things to keep in mind that while
she's not a true villain in this story
the position of wonder woman is more of
as we said in the last video when you're
a hammer everything is a nail and so she
doesn't really understand the nature of
diplomacy she does to a degree insofar
as an ambassador from themyscira to
humanity can understand diplomacy but
there's a lot more to it there's nuance
there's a much bigger scene going on
here with regards to all these
meta-humans which is like we mentioned
before they have no real leader there's
no quote-unquote parent teaching them
how to function in this world without
superman this is what the world looks
like when you have metahumans and no one
likes superman to inspire guide or lead
them now the other part of this is that
in order for the prison to function
effectively and actually house these
people the justice league needed someone
who was capable of building a prison
that no one could escape from and could
only do that by being someone that could
escape from any prison they basically
enlisted scot-free mr miracle now we're
not given a whole lot about him for all
you super hardcore mr miracle fans i'm
sorry to say
we don't get a whole lot about this guy
all we're really told is that he was the
one that was instrumental in building
the prison building a place that no one
could escape from because he's a master
escape artist who can escape from
anywhere so if if he can build a place
no one can get out of that means no one
can get out of it but the bigger issue
that you have to contend with is that
what superman was trying to do was
balance the humanity of meta humans with
a prison system and so what he ended up
creating was this situation where you
had all these people who were there but
they all kind of had free reign they
could sort of move around and they could
do their thing he didn't want them to
feel like they were in some kind of like
a concentration camp or something that
starts to present a lot of issues
because what he does is he presents
himself to these people as someone that
can lead them into a better future but
the reality is the life they know is the
only life they've known they haven't
known a life where there's been some
greater force out there that can show
them the way all they've known is this
vigilantism so to them that's the
definitive life right it's one of those
things those of you guys who are
familiar with the allegory of plato's
cave that's what this is those of you
guys who don't know what that is the
allegory of plato's cave is this idea
that if you had like three people who
had basically spent their entire life in
a cave and all they ever saw of the real
world were shadows projected on the cave
wall to them that is the real world
right for us we know that it's not real
but it is real to them and so if you
were to take them out of that cave and
you were to show them the world as it
really exists they would reject it as
incomprehensible because it just defies
everything they know and as we know as
people in times of desperation people
will believe what they want to believe
logic and reason and emotion have no
bearing on that it's just whatever makes
them feel the most comfortable and what
makes these people feel comfortable is
the life that they've been living
suddenly this guy just comes out of
nowhere quite literally strips them of
this life they had throws them into what
is in effect a prison system and then
says i'm here to improve you from their
perspective it's but there's nothing
wrong with me because they don't believe
there's anything wrong with him that's
why he's met with so much hostility and
so what you have is this kind of fight
that begins to break out to a degree but
it all has quelled pretty quickly but it
really is one of these things where
superman is in over his head he's
putting too much faith in those who
cannot who just cannot be trusted in
that way right he's putting trust in
people who have no reason to be trusted
he's trying to fix the broken who are
beyond repair and so that's what's kind
of crazy is because while all this goes
on you have of course the uh the mankind
liberation front that's watching all of
this unfold and coming to this
realization that nothing that superman
is trying to achieve is actually going
to work he is fighting a fool's errand
beyond that what you also have is the
quintessence now the quintessence are
basically a coming together of cosmic
forces if you want to call them that so
think of the quintessence as dc's
equivalent to the the sky fathers but on
seemingly a higher level of power
honestly there's no direct translation
between the quintessence and the sky
fathers but the sky fathers that marvel
has is about the closest you get to this
but within the dc landscape these are
some heavy hitters the spectre the
phantom stranger uh the wizard shazam
you have ganthet of the of the green
lantern or the guardians of the of the
universe you have some heavy hitters
here they're kind of an inner council
that basically monitors and watches
things to see how the universe unfolds
now the funny situation about this is
that as the specter is watching all this
unfold that you have the quintessence
that's just like whatever happens on
earth that's their problem right earth
is a single world right it's just a just
tiny little ball of mud in an infinitely
expanding universe there's much bigger
things and more important things that we
need to worry about and the spectre
asked the question is that so and when
the answer or the response of the of the
quintessence is yes and he says then why
do you all spend so much time dealing
with humanity why are you observing this
for such a lengthy period of time if
humanity matters so little you would
give them no more of a thought than you
would some comet streaming across the
cosmos but you're facing like you're
literally focusing on humanity you're
focusing on this whole thing so on some
base level it's entirely possible that
you congregate in order to prevent each
other from interfering that each one of
you wants to be involved in your own way
you gant that want to gather the green
lantern court and send the green lantern
corps in to quell this entire thing you
phantom stranger want to do something
else or you the wizard shazam want to
step in in some capacity but each of you
have agreed to remain hands off you care
more than you're willing to admit now a
really important moment in this story
comes when norm and mckay watching all
this unfold really just can't understand
can't hear anything they're saying
because i guess the conversation is not
meant for him that's really what he
speculates he's met by the arrival of
boston brand now boston brand being dead
man this is when we're starting to get
into this idea of the the religious and
mythological side of dc comics right for
those of you guys who are new to dc dc
has two sides you've got the
front-facing superhero side that's the
face they present to the general public
anybody who wants to start getting into
comics that's your superman batman
wonder woman justice league comics then
you have the other side you've got like
the vertical side the the idea of
mysticism religion god lucifer all that
kind of stuff boston brand and
everything the specter that's the other
part that's the mystical side the
religious side boston brand whenever you
see him usually in a story like this he
possesses somebody not always but the
idea of boston brand is that he's well
aware of the spectre and the phantom
stranger and this whole side of things
norman mckay is not and so where norman
mckay is basically a pastor who's
devoted his life to the belief in god
basically the presence that kind of a
thing showing up here and encountering
all this it is to a degree questioning
his faith and not to really be a
terrible person about it but boston
brand kind of pushes him over a little
bit further because what he basically
tells him is that you have no idea
what's really going on here in the
greater world do you like you read your
bible to your congregation you take the
words that you see in the book with an
absolute faith that up to this moment
can never truly be shaken you believed
that it was true but you never actually
had the facts you never really knew what
was going on now norman mckay can't
really be faulted for that because no
one had taken him on a journey like this
before nothing had ever happened in his
life that led him to believe that while
the book he was reading wasn't
necessarily false there was just more to
the to the equation than he was seeing
but what boston brand says is one you're
being taken on this ride by the spectre
and it is important that you undergo
this but one thing to know the spectre
just because he's some being out there
of divine nature does not mean he's
inherently good it does not mean that
that's the case he's like one of the
things you need to understand is that
when it comes to the notion of good and
evil that sure you've got things like
the presence you've got lucifer and all
the stuff contained within your book but
the reality here is the the situation as
it exists the real world as it you know
as if you could call it that right what
passes for you know a lack of a better
word here it's anything but that it's
just varying shades of grey good and
evil do not really exist out there it's
just whatever a person can do and can't
do so do not take everything the specter
tells you as an absolute truth he was
bonded to jim corgan he was a cop at one
point in time when he was just the
spirit of vengeance he went crazy
basically lost his mind became what you
would call evil for a while the guy is
not some genuine altruistic force out
there designed to just punish the wicked
on behalf of god it's not that that
black and white it's not that binary and
so he says take what he tells you right
listen to what he tells you and keep it
in the back of your head just don't take
it as an absolute truth and then he
basically walks away now this particular
moment with boston brand will become
incredibly important once we get to the
end of the story because it'll totally
change the way that norman mckay handles
things but on the other side of the
equation regarding the whole idea of the
mankind liberation front one of the
questions that i imagine a lot of you
all have is why is billy batson working
with lex luthor so the way this works is
we're not really given a definitive
answer here we'll actually get that here
in a little bit it'll really be on
behalf of batman that explains it the
thing behind this though is that billy
batson here as an adult is constantly
showed footage of superheroes just being
violent how superheroes are quote
unquote inherently bad now it's not
really lex luthor cooking the books here
he's showing uh shazam actual footage
he's showing him these actual things
that go on the difference is that much
like most things that exist here in the
world on the media side news and so on
and so forth he's only ever been given
one half of the story to serve a
particular purpose the other part of
this and what like lex luthor is doing
is he's channeling the knowledge of dr
savannah right mr mind now one of the
things to keep in mind is that kingdom
come is post crisis on infinite earth
but before the new 52 so the new 52
origin of mr mind and dr savannah don't
really apply here instead going by the
power of shazam way back in the 1990s
and 1996 that the way this played out is
that mr mine had basically taken over
savannah and then planned like an
invasion of earth right that kind of
thing what we're not told here but what
seems to be the case is that with mr
mind being a sentient being that can
operate by his own whim his own will and
desire and so on and so forth that maybe
something happened somehow dr savannah
managed to overpower mr mind or whatever
it is but the idea of a telepathic worm
was basically used here we're not really
given the details about how all this
unfolded all we know is using a worm to
mentally control other individuals
around him is how lex luthor's been
controlling shazam so there's a lot of
ambiguity there but one of the things
that does go on here is you do end up
having batman who's actually watching
all this unfold using a secret spy
device now of course what's also taking
place here is working with the the
mankind liberation front they're
basically weaponizing and creating a
whole bunch of these mech bats right
these these bat robots that can be used
to kind of operate in lieu of metahumans
in order to keep society in check now
one of the things that batman wanted to
establish with lex luthor is that what
they're looking for is to basically move
the world in a better direction right to
create world order not world domination
they're not looking to subjugate
humanity they're looking to lead
humanity in a better to a better future
and believe they can only do that
because they themselves are humans that
many humans just can't relate to
humanity in that way right because they
simply have a level of power that
humanity doesn't possess right that at
the end of the day if mankind were to
follow the will of god it would be due
more to fear than an actual love or
belief in the power that person
possesses and so what you have here for
the most part when it comes to uh to
billy batson walking around is he
basically seems very inhuman in terms of
his appearance he smiles all the time
and never really shows any emotion or
anything like that and so it really it
really freaks people out it creeps them
out in a lot of ways like why is this
guy always smiling and looking like that
well he looks like a robot like it's
just kind of strange and so what you
also have going on here and this is one
of the more important things that we
don't get a lot of a lot of exposition
on is martian manhunter because that's
probably a question that a lot of people
had where's martian manhunter in all of
this now what we end up finding out is
that martian manhunter basically keeps
himself under the guise as a regular guy
that you that at least attempting to use
the telepathy of martian manhunter is
very very limited here in order to keep
anybody from knowing what he actually is
and the reason why is because this guy's
mind is walking a nice edge that
following superman basically walking
away martian manhunter in
what was probably the most terrible
decision he could make had actually
telepathically reached out to the whole
of humanity and experiencing all of the
nature of humanity at one point in time
basically broke him but humanity like
the very core of human beings broke
martian manhunter he never truly
understood what humanity was about until
he touched all their minds at the same
time and so because of that where
there's an attempt by batman to utilize
the powers of of martian manhunter to
effectively read the minds of the people
in the room to find out what their
actual goals and motivations are in the
end it simply just proves to be too much
and so martian manhunter just kind of
goes about his business and that's
seemingly the last we see of him for a
while but the thing about this is you do
have this kind of moment in the the
watchtower or really the i guess the
citadel of the green lantern where the
justice league watches everything and
for the most part they've quelled most
all of these meta-human threats that
exist around the world just by arbitrary
fighting and whatnot things have calmed
down right germany's clear all these
different locations but the funny thing
about this is that the flash picks up on
the presence of norman mckay and as a
result of that actually yanks norman
mckay out of this kind of invisible
barrier so to speak because the reality
is that with the spectre they had him
slightly out of phase with the universe
itself but as the flash he can phase
through dimensions so it was only a
matter of time before he saw something
that indicated norma mckay was there as
soon as he picked up on it norman mckays
yanked out he subdued by power woman and
then questioned by superman and when he
when superman asked the question like
who are you and why are you here the
reality is that witnessing this guy's
presence firsthand actually meeting him
firsthand overwhelms norman mckay he
doesn't quite know how to respond he
ends up turning into what's basically a
babbling fool all the way to the point
that he starts basically running off
biblical scripture by just saying like
well the end times are coming and that
kind of stuff he sounds like a religious
kook babbling about how the the how
armageddon is coming the end of days is
here some crazy person that you would
just walk by on the side of the road and
pay no attention to and that's kind of
what superman does they basically
dismiss him because the well while this
is going on you have dick grayson as
robin who chimes in and says like
there's a riot in the gulag right like
we have to get to the gulag we have to
respawn and of course wonder woman steps
in and basically tells everybody what
they need to do and sends them out there
and then a great big huge debate takes
place between wonder woman and superman
when he asks the question why did you
override my authority why did you
undermine me and the the response of her
is why did i do that i saw a crisis i
reacted in a confident and unequaled
manner the others need to see that sort
of authority from someone pull yourself
together we're overdue for a meeting
with the united nations they can't help
but know about the gulag by now and the
response of superman is that i guarantee
you they're wondering when we started
making up our own laws let's go and in
meeting with the united nations
basically the overall gist of this
conversation is humanity is losing faith
in the meta humans they're losing faith
in superman's ability to keep this
entire threat under control because
where superman responded by saying i can
corral them in i can get this whole
thing sorted out the reality here is
he's losing control that the gulag was
created as a prison he did what was
probably the worst possible thing which
is take all these people with all this
power and put them into one single
location it's a melting pot of just
anger and rage and madness that's
literally what it is tempers running
high the whole nine yards you've got
villains who are now being housed with
heroes because that's kind of how they
see themselves to a degree they all they
do all they know how to do is just fight
and so because that's all they know how
to do when it comes to solving their
problems any disagreement that that
arises between these different meta
humans is met with conflict they don't
understand the idea of diplomacy or
talking things down or having a
conversation or any of that stuff they
don't know there's a better way while
that whole thing goes down with regards
to this crisis in the gulag you do have
the the mankind liberation front that
finally decides it's the time to make
their move it's their time to decide
what it is that they're going to do
right how they're going to act here now
you do have lex luthor who effectively
grabs shazam and says now's the chance
right now's your time to deal with this
and when that happens batman
incapacitates lex luthor and that's what
we end up finding out that's why batman
was here in the first place that he
never really joined the the mankind
liberation front never really even
believed in their movement in the first
place what he wanted to know is what
happened with billy batson what's going
on with shazam because the reality here
is that shazam is probably the only guy
out there that can go toe-to-toe with
superman and in fact that's gonna be a
major component of this story when we
get to part four superman versus shazam
but it's a really cool thing because
what we end up getting is this
explanation where batman had figured it
out and he says i'd suspected for a
while and jon jones telepathic probe
confirmed it it seems marvel's dual
identities are in quite a bit of mental
conflict all these years as batson grew
to manhood luther kept him in check by
turning him into a stew of schizophrenic
psychosis and he says my only goal in
allying with you was to learn your
connection to captain marvel in the
entire global conflict he was the wild
card and i hate wild cards and so that's
the crazy thing here is because now we
know that when billy batson was a little
kid and superman had basically walked
away that that essentially lex luthor
took billy batson under his wing and
then using basically telepathic worms
the knowledge of mr mind or of dr
savannah had been keeping billy batson
under his thrall under his control the
problem here is you have batman who
tells his guys take out the mankind
liberation front right deal with those
guys and at the same time you also have
billy batson who basically races off
under the orders of lex luthor to find
superman and to deal with him but again
billy batson is still under the control
of lex luthor but that's the concern
that you have when it comes to batman is
because when he confronts uh shazam when
he finally you know encounters him and
you've got all these tubes that are
filled with all these worms that lex
luthor's been using on shazam and they
all start to kind of infiltrate billy
batson he finally shouts the word shazam
and becomes a superhero self and then
takes off at the direction of lex luthor
to find superman so that's the big issue
is what happens when these two meet how
is it all going to go down and so when
you have wonder woman and you have
superman who arrived back at the uh at
the the watchtower i guess we can just
start calling it that right like the
emerald citadel the justice league
watchtower is effectively what it is a
great big huge argument breaks out
between the two because what you have
here is this this point where superman
says yet another side of you that i'm
not comfortable with right this part of
you that's willing to do whatever it
takes to win and the response of her is
get used to this one a soldier
unprepared has no business calling
herself a soldier and the response to
superman is you know quote unquote more
amazonian wisdom right isn't it possible
that we've already won the big fight
once the rioters are calmed we can
instill some measure of peace and the
response of wonder woman is you always
were a bit vulnerable to magic because
superman cut himself on her sword be
careful the sword was a gift from
hephaestus it can carve the electrons
off an atom and and the question of
superman is did you expect to use that
on me and she says i expected to be a
soldier right so what this indicates is
that if it came down to it wonder woman
was willing to kill superman she was
willing to take him out that the sword
was effectively a backup plan and he
says i will not sanction lethal force
against me or any of the rioters i'm
uneasy with that blade because that's
the other part of the equation sure it
can be used on superman if it needs to
be but she's willing to kill those meta
humans superman is not and that's the
discussion that we had in the previous
video in any particular conflict wartime
video games sports whatever it is right
they're all forms of conflict there's
only ever two people involved or two
types of people involved at any
particular point in time the ones who
would like to win and the ones who want
to win who need to win and the ones who
would like to win are not usually the
ones who win because the ones who feel
like they need to win or have to win
they'll do whatever it takes the only
thing that matters is that they come out
on top superman is by all standards of
measurement what you would call a high
road defeatist he's a person that takes
the stance of saying i would rather die
and keep my morals intact right i would
rather lose and keep my morals then win
by betraying them but the reality here
is of what use would that do to anybody
right if the one who loses and keeps
their morals intact if they die if
they're out of the picture now all
that's left is the one who wins and
whatever it is that they want to do
there's no one there to stand in the way
so in effect they've quit they're a
defeatist they gave up right literally
maintaining their moral code is what
caused them to lose in the first place
and that's the real position here wonder
woman is the one that has to win that
needs to win she's the one that's
willing to beg borrow steal and kill for
superman it's a war of convenience and
that's why you see this conflict
unfolding the way that it is because he
says there are lines that we do not
cross we have rules and her stance is
and the prisoners don't that's why
they're prisoners and if they don't
remain prisoners your big blue marble
teeters on the brink you made the
decision to incarcerate them for the
good of mankind remember and he says and
maybe that was my mistake maybe i should
have let the humans decide how to deal
with this but at the end of the day it
was superman's screw-up that what he
failed to realize is that he's basically
fighting a war against people who don't
follow the rules while following the
rules himself and that desire to follow
the rules is how you lose that's his
weakness and so as this whole thing all
the whole thing unfolds you end up
having this communication that comes
from the green lantern who's like we
can't hold this right these guys are
just way too powerful for us there's too
many of them they're overpowering us
they're reaching the walls we cannot
keep this thing contained somebody has
to do something and we end up finding
out that one of the people that one of
the superheroes had been killed captain
comet had died so now members of the
justice league are dying because of
superman's high road defeatist attitude
and so what this does is it leads to
wonder woman stepping in and saying then
we're gonna go there and we're gonna do
whatever we have to do if that means we
have to kill every single metahuman
that's housed in the gulag we'll kill
every single one either you can stay
back here and you can hope that things
work out or you can join us in this
conflict you can grow some balls and you
can make the decisions that need to be
made because this is a time of war are
you a winner or are you a loser choose
one and ultimately superman stays behind
and so that's one of the crazy things is
because in this moment he races off
actually where wonder woman takes off to
the gulag he races off to batman and
confronts him and says i need your help
and where batman's like no we've been
through that already superman fed up is
like i've had enough of this right this
is not the time for you to take some
kind of high road or be a dick or
anything like that right this there are
huge stakes here we literally have meta
humans breaking out of this the united
nations is waiting on pins and needles
to decide what it is they're going to do
and if it comes down to it they're going
to go to the nuclear option so they
could very well just wipe us all out as
metahumans the entirety of our future
hinges on this it hinges on this whole
thing and the response of batman is what
did you think was going to happen you
took every single metahuman that you
deemed to be a bad guy and put them in
one place you took a huge group of
people tons of people who don't know how
to solve any problem other than fighting
over it and you put them in one place
and gave them free reign you created
this circumstance you set this whole
thing up you're the reason why this is
happening in the first place it even
says like do you mean to tell me
superman that you you you mean to tell
me you never imagined that it might come
to this did you ever consider that war
might actually be for the best that
perhaps humanity's only chance is for
the superhumans to swallow each other
right to basically annihilate each other
it's the best chance humanity has of any
of having any kind of meaningful future
and this debate back and forth rages in
such a way to where it's like either you
can do something or a batman or you can
do nothing because lest we forget you're
a member of the justice league and so
before you take this high stance of it
is humanity's chance right it's time for
superhumans to go you were along with us
you're the smartest man in the world
maybe depending on lex luthor do you
really think they're not gonna come
after you do you really think they're
gonna say well all the metahumans have
to go and by metahumans we mean anybody
who has powers batman's cool do you
really think that's what they're gonna
say no they're gonna come after you
because you have the ability to affect
the world on a global scale maybe not
with powers but certainly with your
intelligence you represent a clear and
present danger and then the response of
batman here is like okay fine and he
says i will tell you this one thing i'm
not going to help you on all this but i
will tell you this one thing there's a
player that you have not counted on and
that's marvel that's literally captain
marvel billy batson and superman's taken
aback and he says he's been brainwashed
severely once there was a good kid
inside him but he's basically been
driven out and i don't know how you'd
ever find him again he's lost right
billy batson is headed to the gulag he's
gonna break it wide open onto the
justice league he's literally gonna
unleash all the superheroes out there
and he's going to initiate a
circumstance where humanity is going to
respond with nuclear arms and when that
happens it's game over right like it's
that's it there's no coming back you all
get nuked maybe some of you survive but
ultimately the entirety of the human
race will see you as the reason why it
happened and so ultimately you end up
having shazam who arrives on the scene
superman gets there just in time right
tries to get there just just before it
happens but he's too late shazam smashes
the place open right as superman gets
there and then before he can do anything
shazam stops him dead in his tracks with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace